13,279
bellow players need to see this. Ah, I
see you built a bellow deck because it's
the new and shiny and you get to play
enchantress, but you skip the part where
you have to think. Yeah, squirrel
players be like that. You probably
needed your opponents to explain to you
how your own cards worked with your
commander. And the card we have today
may need some explaining, maybe just a
bit more complicated than I see a smash,
but it's okay, I'm a level one judge and
I got you.
Titania's song.
See, it's even bard themed. And this
art, man, your opponents probably won't
be able to stop looking at it while you
lock down their artifacts. Sure, they
have more blockers now, but who has the
biggest artifacts and enchantments? You
do, because that's literally the point
of your deck. Oh, and you've been
hearing a lot of complaining about
treasures? Not anymore. Nice smothering
tithe you have there. Okay, any
questions? Yes, Jimmy. Oh, what about
our own artifacts? Are those locked,
too? Good question, Jimmy, except you
remember how bellow turns your big
artifacts into creatures? Yeah, so those
are unaffected, so you can still draw
with your one ring. I'm pretty sure this
works. If your opponents question you,
just yell "Layers!" Or "Timestamp!" I
don't actually know which is which, I'm
just a level one judge. Also, I'm pretty
sure neither actually applies here, but
you're just a dumb squirrel player. If
your opponents want to get all academic
here, they can look it up. Keep
smashing.